[Music]
thank you
hello and thank you for joining us on
spectator TV Posey um I think the first
question is given the events of the the
past week um how are you and what
exactly happened on your trip down under
oh gosh what didn't happen on my trip
down under it was a full spectrum of
experience which started with me when I
landed in Sydney saying to my husband we
could move here it's such a lovely
wonderful friendly place to um by the
end of it leaving New Zealand with pre
police protection where nobody could
even know where I was in the station and
having a police escort until I got on
the plane until the plane took off so um
full spectrum of stuff uh you know
mobbing uh all that stuff
yeah I mean you've obviously done a
number of these kind of events before
you've enlisted reactions a positive
negative before I mean were you
surprised by the intensity of feelings
uh which happened on your tour Down
Under
um yes I was so I look I knew it was
going to be hostile because we are in a
a bizarre episode of human history in
which
um normal people that understand the
truth are fighting against sort of a
quasi-religious authoritarian cult so I
knew that it was going to be difficult
and
but what normally happens in these
situations is you get the the
um
the people that that are part of the
cult that will be very very angry with
you and uh shape dogmatic mantras at you
uh and that's that's understandable and
that's I I accept that and they are
almost invited because they they proved
my point really as to why I don't want
them in women-only spaces but once we
stepped into calling me a white
nationalist
um and a Nazi which was done by people
in Authority then I'm fair game just to
be killed in the street so it just took
on a a totally different uh feel and
also I think it most people don't want
men in their spaces they don't want men
in spaces with their daughters and so I
it's unlikely I'm just going to meet
some random person on the street that
doesn't agree with me
um but you know that's that's not the
case when I'm all over the news on a
daily basis trending on a daily basis as
kind of uh more poisonous than a funnel
web spider
and but you mentioned there you know
talking about going around Australia and
New Zealand and you mentioned in your
answer there about those in Authority
who let you down who exactly used to
blame there because obviously there was
a visceral demonstration on the streets
and you talk about in your piece uh but
for the explanation of those who are
watching this
um particularly the failings of the the
police in New Zealand why do you think
this is and how exactly did they let you
down
well I want to just make it really clear
that the officers that looked after me
in New Zealand were incredible they were
they were lovely
um they are nothing to do with the
decision-making process which basically
held back police
out of the place where the mobbing
happened I mean I got taken to the
middle of the mob
to stand on a Bandstand
um and when I got there I just I had no
idea the police weren't there I just
assume because they said they cooperate
I mean they said it they they wanted to
know where I was before I got in the
country and so I assumed that meant they
were going to protect me and they took
it really seriously because I'd been
escorted in a couple of airports by
Australian police but instead when I got
there I was searched for two hours and
interrogated uh my hotel had already
canceled and then when I got to the
hotel when I woke up the next day I had
a threatening letter under my door so I
probably shouldn't have been surprised
and I felt it right I'm not particularly
a spiritual person or believe in those
sorts of things but I felt it in my
bones I was very afraid actually going
to the event
and there was an activist who assaulted
You by pouring tomato juice in your your
head and then gave a very sort of
boastful interview to television before
flying to Australia and then the police
said they wouldn't arrest her arrest
them I mean do you think that you were
sort of insufficiently supported against
those kind of kind of threats and that
clearly the people who were doing this
sort of stuff felt they were powered to
do things such as cover you in tomato
juice
um I think they they uh act as if
there's no consequences whatsoever and
to sort of gloat about it uh especially
when apparently that person has Refugee
status and now has committed an act of
common assault which uh you know I'm now
drinking my suit cold so I'm quite happy
about that
um I think there are going to be some
consequences but yeah the protesters
should not have been allowed anywhere
near women who just want to speak I mean
it's been called a counter protest we
are not protesting we are just Gathering
to speak
um and so there is a protest against
women speaking uh all in every single
City we encountered and it just got
worse and worse and worse for how much
they were allowed to really terrorize
women
you've been you've done a lot of these
kind of overseas tours and around the
country as well I mean do you get a
sense perhaps that the the debate on
these kind of issues is very different
in Australia and New Zealand and to what
extent do you think nationally does
people like Jacinda Arden are to blame
for clearly they're very powerless and
dangerous state of political debate down
there
well I think um we just looked to
lockdowns and I think there's a
correlation between the authoritarian
attitude of those
um governments in lockdown and what you
can force a population to do and this
this adherence to this brand new
um ideology of pretending that we don't
know what biological sex is there does
seem to be a correlation
um I just don't it was just so weird to
be in a a situation that was clearly
very dangerous really violent could have
ended up with any one of us women
um having our lives taken and all over
placards there's uh talking about be me
um dying and being stomped on and
exterminated and all of these things and
that shouldn't have even been allowed at
all but we've lots of Nations have been
allowing this you know whether it's how
we protest against world leaders when
they come here
um you know more likely to protest Trump
than than they were somebody who's in a
sort of a theophysistic kind of
authoritarian country uh there's there's
something really bizarre going on and
none of it feels real
sort of hierarchy of different protests
with them perhaps uneven standards
between all of that
um you know yeah from the sound of it
and lies I mean the media in New Zealand
is is nuts they just lied I mean they
didn't they didn't exaggerate they
didn't just exaggerate they didn't just
extrapolate they they actually lied
um they blurred my hand and pretended I
was doing a white power signal they they
whipped up I mean maybe there's no news
in in New Zealand who knows but they
whipped up a frenzy I was I was trending
in those areas and I was on the news
channels every single night with you
know serious politicians coming out and
lying about me and saying that I was a
really dangerous person and never
talking about really any of the issues
that the women want to talk about in
their countries just sort of saying that
I had these uh guilt by association uh
relationships with a variety of people
that I've never met never talked to I've
got nothing to do with uh and just with
people up into this frenzy it's it's a
sight to behold you mentioned the women
there what do they tell you and do they
sort of compare your experiences with
theirs and sort of comment on the kind
of nature of women in political debate
in Australia and New Zealand
yes so
um there's already uh self ID in most of
Australia
um they talk about the sexualization of
children and I saw government literature
where it described babies age naught two
having a sexuality
um and talking about babies sort of
touching their bodies being sort of
forming their sexual identity it's uh
it's truly the worst of everything is
probably in in our Fair Isles is
Scotland and it's it's worse in uh
Australian and New Zealand than it is in
Scotland and Scotland is pretty bad
I mean I think there's often there's a
worldwide Trend in these things where
you know it seemed for a long time like
most western democracies were pushing
towards self-identification and now
perhaps in recent events uh you see
obviously through the backlash what was
happening in Scotland with the gender
recognition Reform Bill
um you've seen the world world Athletics
committee come out against of Elite
Sport transgender participation in that
uh it seems perhaps maybe that there's a
kind of pushback or a sort of change in
the National mood on these Trends did
you detect anything like that in
Australia or New Zealand because it
sounds as though it was very much the
opposite
well it's the same in every country that
it's this weird covert
um attack on policy before it ever
spills out into uh the public discourse
and that's happened in Australia New
Zealand uh a lot worse so before any but
nobody knows what's going on and new
zealanders and Aussies they are really
um I'm not going to say apathetics that
makes them sound like they don't care
but everything's going to be great in
Australia New Zealand everything's fine
everyone just likes each other and gets
on and and so they were ripe really for
this sort of authoritarian creep same in
Canada this authoritarian Creek where
they change all the policies nobody
knows what's going on and then they just
push this sort of coercive manipulation
of the population
um and most people are still thinking
that a man who wants to enter a space
which some people might call a trans
woman I would call a man but a man
wanting to use women's spaces and
pronouns and language Etc
a lot of people still think that that is
a really vulnerable member of the
population who needs looking after and
special sort of Rights and the truth is
it isn't a vulnerable member of a
population that can have a mob of 2 000
people commit acts of violence against
women and not even be condemned that is
not a vulnerable part of our population
and how has this sort of impacted you I
mean looking to the future is it going
to change how you you do you conduct
these tours or how you think about them
or how you engage in the public space or
do you remain more Resolute than ever
what's your kind of takeaways and
lessons from the experiences you went
through in Australia and New Zealand
well I'm upping my own personal security
which is
frankly expensive
um so I'm upping my personal security
plus I'm just about to enter politics
and I'm going to go stand against
kirstama so
um I'm going to be even more known
um and I think the attacks upon me are
going to be more vitriolic so that's one
thing I'm doing uh I think unless we get
really good uh agreements from police
when I travel so I'm supposed to go to
Northern Ireland and Ireland
um and now that they've upped the
terrorism threat in Northern Ireland I
think that would be silly to put women
at grave risk so I won't be doing that
but you know I'm going to tell uh the
police in this country that they
absolutely have a duty to look after us
otherwise what we will do as women is we
will stand against every single PCC and
we will win and we will ensure that the
police actually look after women and
that we're safe to speak in the streets
of the United Kingdom
thank you
[Music]